je propose que nous débutions notre
réunion merci
Monsieur de votre présence
enfin cette fin d'après-midi devant la
commission des lois
simplement pour votre information notre
votre audition est retransmise via le
site internet du Sénat pour que les
choses parfaitement claires nous avons
mais vous le savez bien évidemment
auditionné il y a maintenant 15 jours ah
pardon excusez-moi
nous avons déchaîné il y a maintenant 15
jours le maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
monsieur Yannick Morel
qui nous a expliqué ce qu'il avait vécu
les menaces puis les agressions et qui
nous expliquent qu'il avait amené à
présenter sa démission à vous présenter
cette émission
naturellement à l'occasion de son
audition et il a il a dit que
je ne personnalise pas naturellement les
services de l'État ne l'avaient pas
suffisamment accompagné
qu'il avait eu le sentiment d'être seul
et que par ailleurs alors même qu'il
s'agissait la situation
intervenait au moment où un projet
porté par les services de l'État c'est
un projet de cada de centre d'accueil
pour les demandeurs d'asile était
installé sur sa commune que par ailleurs
son conseil municipal avait voté l'unité
d'installation de ce cada et que
finalement au-delà de ses propres
habitants qui avaient
contesté la décision
sa décision d'autres mouvements
d'extrême droite d'ailleurs a-t-il
précisé sont venus se greffer dans ce
conflit local et finalement en faire un
combat qu'on n'a pas jugé ici mais qui
en amener à de la violence à des à des
menaces et à des passages à l'acte
puisqu'il évidemment un incendie a été
déclenché à son domicile et ce de nuit
l'objectif pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
de comprendre j'ai presque dire vue de
votre côté
comment les choses se sont effectivement
passées
et surtout de
comprendre parce que son présent dans
cette salle commission des lois Madame
carraire et Monsieur Darnaud qui sont
tous les deux en charge d'une mission
récemment décidée par le Sénat sur le
rôle de la commune et des mers et donc
de comprendre comment se passe et
comment fonctionne en réalité au
quotidien dans les situations de cette
nature les relations entre
l'État les préfets et les maires
toute la journée dans cette maison on
vante les mérites du couple préfet mère
on est tous d'accord pour dire que c'est
un couple parfaitement
utile encore faut-il savoir comment ça
marche et comment ça fonctionne et si ça
dysfonctionne pourquoi ça dysfonctionne
la question est de cette nature voilà
nous sommes dans une discussion qui est
parfaitement sereine je à vous avertir à
l'avance notre but n'est pas de juger
notre but est de comprendre
et de comprendre ce qui a marché ce qui
n'a pas pu marcher et d'une manière
générale ce qui pourrait être largement
amélioré je rappelle à cet égard que il
y a eu des annonces du gouvernement la
semaine dernière surferme ma part où la
semaine d'avant pour dire qu'il fallait
revoir l'organisation des choses
repenser
la manière dont pouvait fonctionner les
relations entre les préfets et les et
les élus locaux que nous avons pour
notre part pour une initiative à
quelques-uns sur le sujet de la
protection des mers
mais que la mission qui travaille fera
recommandation ou un autre et que votre
participation ici bien sûr il y a le cas
particulier qui nous intéresse mais il y
a aussi d'une manière générale la façon
de voir les choses voilà ce que nous
voulions vous dire en ce début
d'audition et nous allons maintenant
vous laisser la parole peut-être à vous
monsieur Rigoulet rose en tant que
préfet de la région Pays de la Loire
préfet de la Loire-Atlantique puis
ensuite naturellement monsieur Berck et
le sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire merci
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier de nous avoir donné
l'opportunité
aux sous préfet à moi-même de pouvoir
rendre compte des actions menées par
l'État local dans toutes ses composantes
depuis 2021 dans le dossier que vous
avez mentionné monsieur le Président
dans le dossier cada
sur à la fois les antagonistes et des
oppositions qu'il a suscité localement
sur les dispositions prises aussi en
matière d'accompagnement et de sécurité
vous me permettrez évidemment tout
d'abord de renouveler ma solidarité à
Monsieur le Maire de Saint-Brévin qui a
fait l'objet vous l'avez indiqué de
pression indigne d'intimidation un
qualifiable et qui a été élu et son
épouse victime d'un incendie criminel
qui fait actuellement l'objet d'une
enquête judiciaire confiée au pôle
criminel de Nantes avec désignation d'un
juge d'instruction
sa décision de démission motiver pour
des raisons personnelles et familiales
et fonder sur le fait qu'il ne se
sentait plus en situation de pouvoir
exercer ce mandat comme il l'indiqué
dans le courrier qu'il m'a adressé 9 mai
dernier elle est fondée aussi comme il
l'a comme indiqué lors de l'entretien
que j'ai eu avec lui ainsi que devant
l'arpentation nationale et et dans ces
expressions publiques elle est aussi
fondée sur le sentiment d'une absence de
soutien de l'État
qui interpelle et qui interpelle
évidemment
elle n'en est pas moins en effet un
échec collectif et j'en prends ma part
comme représentant territorial de l'État
c'est malheureusement aussi il me semble
un indicateur des conditions de plus en
plus difficiles dans l'exercice des
responsabilités des dépositaires de
l'autorité publique élu au premier rang
singulièrement les mers et je veux ici
devant vous condamner évidemment avec la
plus grande fermeté toute la violence
d'où qu'elles viennent de l'ultra gauche
comme de l'ultra droite
les mers et les élus en général sont un
maillon essentiel de la République et de
notre démocratie et je les mesuré à
chaque poste préfectoral que j'ai occupé
outre-mer comme dans l'Hexagone mais
également dans les responsabilités de
directeur général de services des
collectivités départementales que j'ai
exercées au plus près et sous l'autorité
d'élus
c'est cette conviction qui m'a animée
dès ma prise de poste en
Loire-Atlantique le 30 janvier 2023
puisque dès les premiers jours et les
premières semaines j'ai souhaité aller à
me présenter sur place dans leur
permanence auprès de chaque
parlementaire mais également auprès des
exécutifs des principales collectivités
et des maires chef-lieu d'arrondissement
j'ai également immédiatement comme je le
fais à chaque fois pris la tâche des
présidents d'associations d'élus AMF et
associations des maires ruraux
un webinaire c'est d'ailleurs tenu dès
le 13 mars sur invitation de l'AMF 44
qui avait convié l'ensemble des maires
du département après le courrier
d'installation si j'ose dire que j'avais
envoyé à chacun des 200 centimètres du
département de la Loire-Atlantique
mi-février et dans lequel j'annonçais
justement cette rencontre ce webinaire a
été l'occasion non seulement de me
présenter bien sûr à l'ensemble des
mères connectées mais également de
souligner entouré de toute mon équipe
l'attachement que j'avais pour un
travail de proximité l'écoute de leur
préoccupation et la volonté de
construire ensemble le déploiement des
politiques publiques au plus près des
territoires et à leur côté
cela a également été l'occasion de
réaffirmer ma pleine disponibilité à
l'égard de chacune et chacun des mers en
particulier pour aller visiter leur
commune
ces prises de contact direct sont de mon
point de vue le préalable absolument
nécessaire dès qu'on prend un poste à
responsabilité territoriale
l'actualité sociale du moment a
évidemment pesé sur mes autres priorités
d'agenda et j'ai d'ailleurs pris
beaucoup plus de temps que prévu pour
aller saluer chacun des agents de l'état
des services placés sous ma
responsabilité à la fois départementale
et régional
ce contexte social c'est le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs vous
le connaissez juste un mot pour indiquer
que la dimension de l'ordre public dans
le département est particulièrement à
Nantes a été dense et a nécessité de
mobilisation permanente de jour comme de
nuit parfois du corps préfectoral bien
sûr et un engagement remarquable des
forces de sécurité intérieure à qui je
veux devant vous rendre un hommage
appuyé en moins de trois mois ce sont
plus de 40 manifestations en lien avec
le mouvement de contestation de la
réforme des retraites qui ont mobilisé
des forces en renfort journée nationale
d'action marche aux flambeau
manifestation de contestation
d'interpellation à l'occasion des
manifestations précédentes et blocage
divers port de Saint-Nazaire lycée
rond-point centre d'incinération
plus de 40 manifestations qui ont
engendré des troubles certains très
graves à l'ordre public avec malgré la
grande responsabilité des organisations
syndicales dans l'organisation des
Journées Nationales d'action la présence
de plus en plus importante de casseurs
et d'éléments de l'ultra gauche
constitués en bloc
élément s'en prenant systématiquement et
violemment forces de l'ordre et à
certains bâtiments institutionnels
au-delà de la casse malheureusement
récurrente à Nantes du mobilier urbain
je pense évidemment à la préfecture à la
sous-préfecture de Saint-Nazaire au
conseil départemental à deux reprises ou
encore au tribunal administratif de
Nantes
à titre contextuel la semaine au cours
de laquelle a été commise l'incendie
criminel à l'encontre de Monsieur le
Maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins a été
ponctué d'événements lourds en termes
d'ordre public la veille dans la nuit du
21 et du 22 mars la libération de
l'apompement de Donges pour permettre la
livraison nationale de carburant à
donner lieu à des affrontements violents
sur le site pendant plusieurs heures
malgré le renfort de trois escadrons de
gendarmerie mobile toute la journée du
22 le pont de Saint-Nazaire propriété du
département et axe stratégique en
Loire-Atlantique a été bloqué fortement
dégradée il n'a d'ailleurs été réouvert
à la circulation que le lendemain c'est
d'ailleurs à l'issue de cette opération
de maintien de l'ordre que j'ai appelé
monsieur le maire pour lui témoigner mon
soutien et lui dire que j'étais à sa
totale disposition
le 22 mars le 23 le lendemain était
organisé une JNA avec 5 manifestations
d'ampleur dans le département dont deux
à Nantes et Saint-Nazaire
pardon excusez-moi monsieur le Président
journée nationale d'action
c'est deux dernières manifestations à
Nantes et Saint-Nazaire le 23 ce sont
traduites par des violences importantes
contre les forces de l'ordre et des
attaques ciblées contre certains
bâtiments préfecture avec des agents qui
étaient restés dans les locaux
sous-préfecture avec là aussi des agents
également présents qui a été prise
d'assaut pendant plusieurs heures et
dans l'intensité a nécessité de dégarnir
le dispositif à Nantes pour envoyer en
urgence des renforts à Saint-Nazaire
intrusion également dans le tribunal
administratif et tentative d'incendie de
l'accueil et des locaux
l'intensité des violences de cette
journée et malheureusement illustrée par
le chiffre des 77 policiers militaires
de la gendarmerie nationale qui ont été
blessés ce jour-là
le 24 après une audience fixée en
préfecture depuis 15 jours avec les
députés de la nupesse alors demande qui
comptait la proportionnalité dans
l'usage de la force dans le cadre des
manifestations et voulait appeler mon
attention sur les dépôts de plainte à
l'encontre des forces de sécurité
intérieure je me suis rendu auprès de
mes agents qui avaient eu à subir les
attaques je me suis rendu aussi pour
aller saluer le présent du tribunal
administratif et la chef des personnels
du greffe au tribunal administratif pour
leur témoigner ma solidarité exprime
examiner les dégâts et envisager avec
eux les mesures urgentes en termes de
sécurisation et je suis allé remercier
un certain nombre des membres de forces
de l'ordre parmi les plus durement
éprouvés par les violences de la veille
la semaine précédente à Nantes celle du
13 c'était 4 jours de manifestation avec
mobilisation de force la semaine
suivante était de même physionomie avec
son lot de blocage et de manifestations
et notamment la journée nationale
d'action du 28 réunissant 20 000
manifestants
dans ce contexte nous avons la
gendarmerie de sous-préfet moi-même je
crois accorder une attention immédiate
et requise au maire et à l'incendie dont
il a été victime qui nécessitait notre
soutien à la fois institutionnel et
personnel et nous avons témoigné de jour
même par le sous-préfet le matin et
moi-même l'après-midi ce soutien il me
paraissait important
de vous donner ces éléments de contexte
ou malgré la charge croissante de la
gestion de rendre de l'ordre public je
ne crois pas que l'État est oublié de
soutenir et d'accompagner un maire
lâchement ciblé par un incendie dans
l'origine criminiale a été confirmée et
encore moins ne pas avoir pris ces
éléments au sérieux les gendarmes ont
d'ailleurs pris sans délai les mesures
de protection renforcées au bénéfice de
Monsieur le Maire après l'incendie
criminel j'y reviendrai dans quelques
instants
sur l'accompagnement du projet au long
cours de ce dossier qui n'a pas pu
empêcher le départ de Monsieur le Maire
puisque nous ne pouvons que constater
qu'il s'est senti obligé de donner sa
démission le sous-préfet apportera
également tous les éléments de détails
dont nous devons vous rendre compte
cette démission est évidemment un
événement grave et elle interpelle à
partir du moment où un élu de la
République estime ne plus être en
situation d'exercer le mandat qui lui a
été confié à cause de pression
d'intimidation ou de menaces accentuées
par une récupération politique de
l'extrême droite et des mouvements
nationaux pression venant de l'extérieur
de la commune portée sur le maire sur
les kits municipales mais également qui
rejaillit sur la population de Saint
Brévin et la population de migrants qui
est accueillie depuis plusieurs années
au sein de la structure gérée par notre
opérateur
je veux d'ailleurs le V ici un
malentendu ou une incompréhension qui a
pu aboutir à me prêter des propos qui ne
correspondent pas précisément à ceux que
j'ai tenu lors du point presse que j'ai
fait le 11 mai 2023 après que le maire
m'a envoyé son courrier de démission et
qui seront qui sont reproduits notamment
dans une dépêche AFP de la même date que
je tiens à votre disposition
je n'ai jamais affirmé avoir eu
régulièrement ou de nombreuses fois le
maire au téléphone parce que ce n'est
pas le cas en effet j'ai indiqué à la
presse que je l'avais eu le 10 mai au
téléphone à la réception de son courrier
et lui avait renouvelé mon soutien comme
je l'avais fait à plusieurs reprises
devives voix d'abord directement à deux
reprises le 22 mars et donc le 10 mai et
vient mon secrétaire général qu'il l'a
appelé en mon nom et à m'a demandé
Express le 4 avril pour lui réaffirmer
mon soutien et lui indiquer que nous
allions organiser une audience avec le
collectif anti-cadin pour honorer
l'engagement que Monsieur le Maire avait
pris ce qui a été fait le 26 avril en
concertation avec son cabinet
soutien témoigner ensuite par les
consignes que j'ai données
personnellement de ne pas laisser isoler
la commune son maire et l'équipe
municipale lors des deux manifestations
hostiles à l'implantation du CADA celle
du 25 février et celle du 29 avril
d'abord en mobilisant un dispositif de
fortes intensité en termes de moyens
d'ordre public qui dépasse le cadre
commun pour des manifestations
réunissant moins de 2000 personnes mais
la récupération par l'extrême droite
dépassait il est vrai également le cadre
de la commune mais surtout et au-delà
des forces c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai décidé la présence d'un sous-préfet
physiquement sur place et d'un officier
général de gendarmerie aux côtés de
l'élu présent pour bien marquer ce
soutien et cette accompagnement
ce n'est pas dit non plus avoir organisé
des réunions publiques d'abord pour la
raison que je n'ai pris mes fonctions
que fin janvier 2023 alors que la
concertation sur ce projet s'est
déroulée essentiellement au titre de
l'année 2022 j'ai cependant indiqué sur
la base des comptes-rendus qui m'ont été
faits que le soutien de l'État sur le
dossier du CADA depuis 2021 avait été
constant avec la participation notamment
de l'État aux côtés de la municipalité
de la municipalité dans le cadre de
réunion publique de concertation et
d'échanges je faisais la référence en
particulier aux réunions organisées à
l'initiative de la mairie à l'invitation
de la mairie le 5 octobre et 16 novembre
2021 ainsi qu'à celle du 22 février 2022
associant outre l'opérateur d'État
d'abord les représentants de parents
d'élèves et un enseignant puis
l'ensemble des enseignants puis
l'ensemble des parents d'élèves le 22
février 2022 je faisais également
référence à la chromiologie Haddock qui
a été pilotée par notre opérateur et qui
a fait l'objet de plusieurs réunions le
5 avril 2022 le 3 mai 2022 le 21
novembre 2022 et le 13 avril 2023
réunion associant outre notre opérateur
qui a fait un travail de proximité très
engagé le bailleur l'adjointe en charge
de la vie scolaire le collectif des
Brévinois attentifs et solidaire
et pour les deux premières d'entre elles
le collectif des opposants au projet de
cada ceux-ci ont d'ailleurs cessé leur
participation à l'automne 2022 il
n'était pas présent à la troisième
réunion ce qui correspond d'ailleurs à
la radicalisation de la contestation et
à la récupération politique par la
mouvance d'extrême droite
au-delà de ces éléments factuels je
comprends néanmoins que cela n'a pas
correspondu aux attentes de la
municipalité cela doit nous interroger
sur le moment et les modalités qui
auraient pu mieux correspondre aux
attentes du maire et des élus
sur les mesures prises en matière de
sécurité mise en oeuvre par les tailles
d'un point de vue opérationnel par la
gendarmerie il m'a été rendu compte que
dès le début de la contestation une
attention toute particulière a été
portée par la gendarmerie et précisément
la compagnie Pornic et la compagne et la
brigade pardon de Saint-Brevin à tous
les aspects de ce dossier manifestation
confrontation des antagonistes tractages
tagage sécurité des sites et évidemment
protection des personnes
des liens étroits ont été établis et une
réunion était organisée toutes les deux
semaines entre la mairie et la brigade
de gendarmerie la mairie étant le plus
souvent représenté par l'adjoint en
charge de la sécurité et le commandant
de la communauté de brigades en
complément de ces réunions régulières
certaines ont été organisées au fur et à
mesure notamment de la montée des
tensions soit en préparation des actions
de voie publique soit dans le cas de
sujets plus spécifiques le sous-préfet
reviendra sur l'ensemble de ces réunions
sur les manifestations qui se sont
déroulées à Saint-Brévin les trois
premières le 15 octobre le 8 novembre et
le 11 décembre 2022 ont été sécurisés
par la gendarmerie départementale et ont
donné lieu à quelques invectives sans
plus de troubles à l'ordre public les
deux dernières celle du 25 février du 29
avril ont été caractérisés par la
présence de participants extérieurs à la
commune et pour certains extérieurs au
département à la fois dans le camp pro
comme dans le camp anticada du fait de
la prise en compte de cette
configuration elles ont donné lieu à un
service d'ordre robuste et fortement
démissionné en termes de mobilisation
des forces demandées à la zone et
attribuée trois unités pour celles du 25
février deux unités plus un drone pour
celle du 29 avril le bilan de la
manifestation du 29 avril c'est ainsi
établi une voiture brûlée en marge du
dispositif en dehors du périmètre de
protection appartement appartenant
pardon d'ailleurs un manifestant
anticada
des dégradations de mobilier urbain et
certaines vitrines commerciales
dégradées
on a compté aussi un manifestant blessé
et trois fonctionnaires CRS blessés
également un bilan évidemment
regrettable car tous les troubles à
l'ordre public n'ont plus être évités
mais qui témoignent de la tenue du
dispositif par les forces de l'ordre
dans un contexte compliqué dans une
recherche permanente d'affrontements
fin de troisième point concerne plus
particulièrement le renforcement dédié à
la protection des personnes et plus
spécifiquement celle de Monsieur le
Maire dans ce contexte et suite à
l'incendie du 22 mars
dès le 23 mars était mis en oeuvre un
passage systématique des patrouilles
soit 4 fois par jour devant notre devant
le domicile du maire et de 6 élus
municipaux étaient mis en oeuvre
également l'inscription leur domicile au
fichiers SIP de la gendarmerie et le
renforcement des contacts réguliers qui
s'est traduit dès le 28 mars par
l'organisation d'une réunion à
l'initiative du commandant de compagnie
avec le maire et les élus là aussi le
sous-préfet pourra revenir dans le
détail sur l'ensemble de ces points y
compris le courrier du 7 avril dans
lequel le maire demandait la mise en
place d'une protection renforcée et
auquel de sous préfère répondu le 11
avril
au-delà de tous ces éléments factuels et
de compte rendu et comme je vous
l'indiquais au début nous ne peut en
tant que serviteur de l'Etat en tant que
républicain en tant que citoyen se
satisfaire d'une situation qui aboutit à
ce qu'un maire estime qu'il n'a pas
d'autre choix que de démissionner en
préparant cette audition un examinant
avec attention chacune des pièces
chacune des décisions qui ont pu être
prises je me suis posé deux questions
avec beaucoup d'humilité
est-ce qu'une donnée une information et
passer à la trappe est-ce qu'une
information factuelle n'a pas été
traitée correctement ou prise à sa juste
mesure nous avons tout vérifié pour être
certain que ce n'était pas le cas y
compris la collection des notes du
renseignement territorial depuis 2021
sur Saint-Brevin la deuxième question
c'est ce que nous aurions pu mieux faire
est-ce que nous pouvons faire mieux face
à ce type de situation cette
interrogation je le dis simplement je me
la pose à chaque gestion de crise ou
d'événements depuis que j'exerce des
responsabilités vous l'avez compris dans
mes propos dans le rappel d'effet que
j'ai évoqué et que sous préfet
complétera il me semble avoir prêté dès
mon arrivée de 30 janvier dans ce
département une attention particulière à
cette situation singulière à bien des
égards qui voit un sujet local être pris
en otage par la récupération politique
qui dépasse le dialogue normal d'un
maire avec ses concitoyens
il me semble avoir prêté à cette
situation une attention personnelle pour
essayer de garantir autant que faire ce
peu l'ordre public à Saint-Brévin et
apporter mon soutien en mer et pourtant
malgré ses moyens mobiliser malgré
l'engagement des services de l'État
depuis le départ et particulièrement de
la gendarmerie nationale le maire a
ressenti une forme d'abandon par ce même
état c'est ce sentiment cette perception
qui interroge qui interpelle et qui
m'interpelle à juste titre on peut
d'ailleurs l'aborder sous plusieurs
angles
l'accompagnement de la collectivité
d'abord vis-à-vis du CADA et de la
contestation qui était montante même si
le processus mis en place à l'origine
correspondait semble-t-il à une vision
partagée et que personne ne conteste le
fort engagement de notre opérateur
aurait-il fallu la présence au quotidien
du corps préfectoral en direct dans la
période récente dont j'ai eu à connaître
depuis le 30 janvier lorsqu'une
intervention directe a été sollicitée
j'ai en tout cas souhaité donner suite
sans délai vu la montée des tensions je
fais la référence à l'organisation de la
réunion du 26 avril sous la présidence
du secrétaire général de la préfecture
de Loire-Atlantique suite à une saisine
par mail reçu du directeur de cabinet de
Monsieur le Maire sur une boîte
fonctionnelle de la préfecture le 30
mars et le 3 avril à la suite desquels
le secrétaire général je l'ai indiqué a
appelé en mon nom le maire
s'agissant des menaces que faisaient
encourir les manifestations et la
présence d'extrémistes la mobilisation
de renfort en unité de force mobile et
la présence d'un sous-préfet d'un
officier général de gendarmerie peut
sembler une réponse uniquement en
réaction par rapport à la gestion de ses
événements mais il faut bien se figurer
ce qu'elle implique en terme de
mobilisation de force dans un contexte
je l'ai rappelé où on sollicitait en
permanence la zone et où les événements
s'enchaînés
s'agissant des pressions et des menaces
proférées à la rencontre du maire ou
d'autres personnes d'ailleurs de la
commune et sans interférer évidemment
avec la partie judiciaire les décisions
qui ont été prises l'ont été sur la base
d'une analyse des forces de sécurité
intérieure au regard des éléments
d'information à leur possession de leurs
moyens mobilisables mais aussi du
contexte qui déplaçait en situation de
tension ces décisions à chaque étape où
elles ont été prises sembler adaptées
proportionnée à ce moment-là et dans le
contexte où elles ont été prises
rétrospectivement la question se pose
avec d'autant plus d'acuité puisque des
faits criminels dont a été victimes le
maire ont été commis
dans le contexte de tension qu'on
connaît
mais encore une fois nous agissons sur
la base de l'analyse de ces services
opérationnels j'accepte bien sûr le
questionnement je le formule d'ailleurs
moi-même
et prévenir 100% d'un risque que des
menaces implicites ou explicites
du risque pardon que des menaces
implicites ou explicitent ne se
concrétise est évidemment un objectif
que tout le monde doit partager mais il
faut toutefois se poser la question des
moyens disponibles ou existants pour
l'atteindre
s'agissant enfin du sentiment du maire
tel qu'il a exprimé devant vous comme je
vous l'ai indiqué j'ai essayé dans le
champ de contraintes ce qui était celui
de l'État local à cette période de me
montrer toujours disponible pour
échanger avec lui personnellement par le
biais de mes plus proches collaborateurs
si on fait abstraction du contexte que
je vous ai décrit et rétrospectivement
mon réflexe spontané aurait évidemment
été d'aller saluer en mairie dès la
commission de l'incendie comme je l'ai
fait d'ailleurs lorsque c'était possible
à Nantes en Paray circonstances
au même titre que j'ai toujours ouvert
tous les canaux possibles pour prendre
en compte le ressenti des agents de ces
services de l'état des membres des
forces de sécurité intérieure des
magistrats du tribunal administratif des
exécutifs et des élus du conseil
départemental ou de la ville de Nantes
ou encore par exemple le ressenti des
commerçants qui subissaient nombreuses
dégradations à chacune des
manifestations ces canaux ont-ils été
suffisants pour percevoir l'ampleur du
désarroi y compris personnel de Monsieur
le Maire de toute évidence non puisque
le résultat et la démission du maire là
encore on doit toujours se demander si
et comment on aurait pu mieux faire et
les moyens dont il faudrait disposer
pour aller au bout de cette logique
peut-être est-ce aussi à cette dimension
d'échanges formalisés et à la meilleure
prise en compte de souffrance qui ne
s'expriment pas aisément que pourra
répondre le réseau des référents et la
création du Centre d'analyse et de lutte
contre les atteintes aux élus
annonçaient le 17 mai dernier par le
gouvernement et à laquelle il faut que
nous soyons toujours toujours plus
attentifs incontestablement
pour conclure je comprends qu'un
sentiment d'isolement puisqu'on dit au
découragement les circonstances ou leur
enchaînement en dépit de ce qui a été
entreprises n'ont pas permis j'en prends
ma part je l'ai dit d'anticiper la
volonté de Monsieur le Maire de
démissionner alors même que chaque
démission est une défaite pour la
démocratie
de toute situation de ce type et
notamment de situations difficiles y
compris dans leur dimension personnelle
et familiale il faut en tirer des
enseignements rétrospectivement et pour
l'avenir et adapter les réponses encore
plus pour éviter un acte aussi grave
pour la démocratie que la démission d'un
maire ou de toute élu d'ailleurs
confronté un exercice de leur
responsabilité à la fois de plus en plus
exigeants et de plus en plus difficile
c'est le cœur même de l'action d'État
territorial aux côtés des élus de la
République je vous remercie merci
Monsieur le Préfet pour ce propos m'a
donné tout de suite la parole Monsieur
le Préfet Berg et vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je suis en poste
comme sous préfet de l'arrondissement de
Saint-Nazaire depuis le 3 décembre 2018
à ce titre j'étais présent depuis le
début du dossier de création d'un cada
collectif sur la commune de Saint-Brévin
je vais donc en propos liminaire vous
présenter aussi succinctement que
possible le déroulement de ce dossier
qui a conduit comme il a indiqué le
maire de la commune a présenté sa
démission
depuis 2016 un centre d'accueil et
d'orientation pour demandeurs d'asile
devenu en 2019 accueille d'urgence de
demandeurs d'asile a été créé sur la
commune de Saint-Brévin dans un centre
de vacances appartenant aux oeuvres
sociales d'EDF loué à l'année et géré
par une association opérateur de l'État
les personnes hébergées ne posent ne
posent aucune difficulté particulière
dans la commune de la vie même du maire
avec qui je m'en étais entretenu
quelques temps après mon arrivée en
poste
début 2021 ma collègue secrétaire
général adjoint de la préfecture en
charge entre autres de ces dossiers
m'apprend qu'il est envisagé de
pérenniser cet accueil provisoire en
transformant cette Ida accueille urgence
des demandeurs d'asile en casa centre
d'accueil et demandeurs d'asile en effet
le CCAS d'EDF souhaitait vendre ce site
et une acquisition impliquée une
pérennisation sous forme de cada
quelques jours plus tard je saisis
l'occasion d'une visite dans la commune
de Saint-Brévin le 11 mars 2021 sur un
tuto de sujet pour en informer le maire
et le député de la circonscription ceci
sur le moment où quelques jours après
par téléphone m'indique la localisation
actuelle dans le centre de vacances ne
leur paraît pas correspondre à la
vocation touristique de ce secteur
je leur indique que l'État est ouvert
d'autres options de localisation sur la
commune pour peu que la municipalité
soit en mesure de proposer un autre site
le 15 avril 2021 la commune propose le
site de la pierre atelique le 12 mai
l'association Aurore opérateur choisi
par l'État pour monter le dossier du
futur cada lance l'étude du dossier sur
ce nouveau site en lien avec le bailleur
social cisn le projet est envoyé au
ministère le 18 juin 2021 qu'il accepte
et j'en informe officiellement le maire
par courrier du 3 août 2021
le 5 octobre 2021 a lieu en mairie sous
la présidence du maire une première
réunion de présentation du projet par
l'opération Aurore à laquelle assiste
des représentants de parents d'élèves
une enseignante les directrices du
centre de loisirs et du centre
périscolaire le choix est fait par la
commune d'une communication ciblée
distribution de tracks dans les boîtes
aux lettres réunion associée en public
concerné sur invitation à l'intention
des enseignants et parents d'élèves de
l'école voisine élargit à quelques
voisins du site une première réunion
aura lieu le 16 novembre au Centre de
Loisirs une deuxième à l'école de la
pierre atelée le 22 février 2022 elle se
rend animées par le directeur
territorial d'Aurore opérateur de l'État
en présence en présence de l'adjointe à
la vie scolaire
toutefois le bulletin municipal
d'octobre 2021 publie un communiqué pour
pour informer l'ensemble de la
population il mentionne à quatre
reprises dans le texte que ce projet est
celui de l'État le journal Ouest-France
reprend cette information dans son
édition du 7 octobre 2021
jusqu'à la réunion du 22 février 2022
aucune opposition au projet ne se
manifeste pour la première fois alors
cette réunion qui réunit toutes les
parties prenantes à peu près une
quarantaine de personnes une dizaine de
parents d'élèves ou de voisins signalent
leurs inquiétudes concernant le projet
il sera à l'initiative de la création du
collectif
de ce fait l'opérateur propose la
création d'un comité de suivi pour
faciliter l'acceptation du projet ouvert
aux opposants et certains y participent
au moins au début ils réunit à quatre
reprises les 5 avril 3 mai et 21
novembre 2022 puis récemment le 13
octobre 13 avril 2023 outre l'opérateur
Aurore l'adjointe et la vie scolaire le
bailleur social le collectif des
Brévinois attentifs et solidaires qui
apporte leur aide leur aide aux
demandeurs d'asile hébergé et pour le
plus récent la gendarmerie
jusqu'à cette réunion de février 2022 ce
projet de transfert ne semble pas
soulever d'opposition toutes les
réunions se déroulent sans difficulté ce
qui n'est pas étonnant la présence des
gens ancienne de demandeurs d'asile sur
la commune ayant posé aucun problème le
dossier est donc traité conformément à
la mission qu'il a été confiée par
l'État par l'opérateur à Rome Aurore la
Direction Départementale de l'emploi du
travail et des solidarités restent à en
appui sur l'autorité du secrétaire
général et de la secrétaire adje général
adjointe de la préfecture
le 9 mars le permis de construire
délivré par la mairie et contesté par le
collectif le recours gracieux est rejeté
le collectif demande un rendez-vous au
préfet qui me charge de les recevoir ce
que je fais le 10 mai 2022 en
sous-préfecture
au cours de cette rencontre avec trois
membres du collectif et après les avoir
écoutés je le rappelle le cadre dans
lequel l'État intervient confirmant que
ce projet est bien porté par lui
l'opposition porte sur le site
d'implantation mais leur marque sont
essentiellement axées sur la supposée
illégalité du permis de construire si je
rejette le remarque sur le opportunité
du choix du site je leur indique que je
vais faire examiner les arguments
juridiques contre le permis développer
devant moi après analyse par la
direction départementale des territoires
et de la mer je leur réponds le 21 juin
2022 que les arguments juridiques
invoqués ne sont pas fondés
par la suite les services de l'État
inspection de l'Académie ministre de
l'intérieur ou moi-même sommes saisis à
plusieurs reprises par courrier ou par
courriel de différents points qui se
révèlent tout aussi incendie je leur
apporte des réponses écrites les 5 août
et 6 décembre 2022 puis le 13 janvier
2023 ainsi qu'à quelques courriers de
particuliers intervenants dans le même
sens
à partir de l'automne 2022 le collectif
baptisé collectif préservation de la
terre attelée non à la localisation du
CADA du nom de l'école et du quartier
organise des manifestations pour marquer
son opposition au projet
le 15 octobre 2022 devant la mairie puis
le 8 novembre devant le futur bâtiment
du CADA c'est manifestations sont
déclarées en Amérique conformément la
loi le collectif de Brévinois attentifs
et solidaires favorable à l'installation
du CADA appelle à une contre
manifestation
le samedi 15 octobre devant la mairie
les anti-cadats sont une cinquantaine à
participer en présence de quelques
militants du rassemblement national le
collectif de Brévinois attentifs et
solidaires favorable à l'implantation à
l'installation du CADA qui a appelé la
veille à une contre manifestation réunit
une centaine de participants la
gendarmerie locale est présente il n'y a
pas d'affrontement entre les deux
groupes seulement quelques-uns à
distance
le mardi 8 novembre la manifestation
enquête anticada devant le futur site ne
réunit que 25 participants sans contre
manifestation
jusqu'ici la contestation est très
locale à la fois juridique et sur la
place publique l'État est pleinement
présent moi-même étant en contact pour
recevoir et répondre ses opposants aux
opposants la gendarmerie départementale
pour gérer les manifestations
une nouvelle manifestation anti-cada est
organisée par le collectif le dimanche
11 décembre celle-ci toujours déclarée
s'annonce plus importante et comporte un
défilé à travers la ville un jour de
marché jusqu'à la mairie on annonce la
participation éventuelle de militants
voire de personnalités politiques
extérieures à la commune
une contre manifestation est également
annoncée sur le bord de mer distant de
la mairie de 150 mètres environ après
une réunion avec des services de
sécurité j'appelle personnellement le
maire sur son téléphone portable le 5
décembre pour lui indiquer qu'il
convient de demander aux anticada une
modification de leur parcours pour
éviter les risques de contact entre les
deux groupes en zone gendarmerie c'est
en effet le maire qui peut prendre ce
type de mesure à l'issue d'une réunion
entre l'adjointe à la sécurité monsieur
de ville conseiller départemental et le
commandant de compagnie de gendarmerie
un nouveau parcours est imposé et les
organisateurs prévenus
ce jour-là 150 participants sont
présents au défilé qui se termine devant
la mairie dont des militants du
rassemblement national du reconquête et
des patriotes 200 militants procada en
statique sur le bord de mer les deux
groupes étant tenus à une bonne distance
par une présente conséquente de la
gendarmerie départementale
du côté du collectif pierre atelier les
slogans sont hostiles au cada bien
évidemment et pour ceux qui concerne les
autorités locales il se limite à de
nombreux morels référendum
on reste du nom du maire
durant cet automne 2022 j'ai l'occasion
de rencontrer le maire au moins deux
reprises le 8 novembre dans la commune
voisine de Paimboeuf pour la signature
d'une convention petite ville de demain
qui concerne sa commune et le 21
novembre à la mairie de Saint-Brevin
pour le comité de pilotage annuel du
contrat de ruralité de relance et
transition écologique entre l'État et la
Communauté de Communes qu'il préside je
rencontre également l'adjoint à la
sécurité monsieur de ville le 18
décembre pour un contrôle sur le feu
d'artifice tiré ce soir-là à
l'initiative de la commune à aucun
moment il est question dans ces
rencontres en marge d'objet de la
réunion de menaces ou de diffamation sur
le maire où les élus de la commune
le 24 janvier 2023 je participe à
Saint-Brevin à une cérémonie de pose de
première pierre de la future brigade de
gendarmerie
la Communauté de Communes étant maître
d'ouvrage le temps est mauvais il pleut
la cérémonie se termine par des discours
dans la salle du conseil municipal la
presse locale est présente et
m'interroge outre sur le sujet du jour
sur le CADA or courant décembre j'avais
reçu en sous-préfecture après les
nombreux autres courriers sur le sujet
auquel j'avais répondu un courrier assez
scandaleux sur la question des migrants
à Saint-Brévin signé d'un collectif donc
non nominatif
et récapitulant toute une série de faits
criminels à travers l'Europe impliquant
des migrants et faisant clairement un
amalgame je saisis donc l'occasion qui
m'est donnée pour dénoncer publiquement
ses propos rappelant que l'État était
responsable de la création du CADA que
l'aménagement du site irait à son terme
et que les propos tenus dans ce courrier
pourraient relever du délit d'injoration
si je n'ai si je développe pas les
injures menaces ou diffamation envers
les élus c'est qu'à ce moment là aucune
information sur de tels agissements nous
ne sont remontés mes propos sont repris
dans deux articles de presse du
lendemain 25 janvier l'un de westfrance
lot de l'autre de Presse Océan je tiens
deux articles à votre disposition
au moment de partir le maire me remets
me dit-il copie d'un courrier adressé
personnellement au préfet Didier Martin
je le lis en rentrant en voiture ce
courrier daté de la veille 23 janvier
dans lequel il évoque pour la première
fois un manque de soutien de l'État sur
la construction du CADA ainsi que des
actes d'intimidation envers l'équipe
municipale en pratique il demande au
préfet de faire ce que je viens de faire
spontanément avant d'avoir pris
connaissance de ce courrier soutenir ce
projet de l'État dénoncé devant la
presse les agissements de l'extrême
droite
en liaison avec le directeur général
France d'Aurore qui vient spécialement
sont organisés pour le vendredi 10
février deux réunions sur la question du
CADA l'une sur le site actuel du CCAS de
DF d’hébergement des migrants avec le
collectif des Brévinois attentifs et
solidaires donc qui assiste les migrants
qui réclament un soutien l'autre en
mairie avec le maire et quelques membres
de la municipalité le commandant de
compagnie de gendarmerie participe
également à cette deuxième réunion
au cours de la réunion avec le collectif
des Brévinois solidaires je les incite à
ne pas organiser leur manifestations aux
mêmes heures que le collectif anticada
pour éviter les risques d'affrontement
ce qu'ils acceptent
au cours de la réunion en mairie le
maire et les adjoints présents des
courriels envoyés aux enseignants et aux
parents d'élèves les tracts distribués
devant l'école et des articles injurieux
sur des sites Internet notamment le site
le site Riposte Laïque et reviennent sur
les manifestations récentes de l'automne
tant le commandant de compagnie que
moi-même insistant sur deux points nous
rappelons à nos interlocuteurs qui
conviennent de distinguer ce qui relève
de la liberté de manifestation et de la
liberté d'expression on a le droit
d'être opposé à la création d'un cada
comme pour toute autre projet important
et de manifester pacifiquement pour le
faire savoir de tracter sur la voie
publique pour faire connaître son
opposition mais il est impératif de
déposer plainte en gendarmerie si des
écrits des articles ou des propos
contiennent des menaces des injures ou
des propos diffamatoires
nous la rappelons également que
malheureusement ce dernier type
d'agissement est désormais très fréquent
que les enquêtes sont généralement assez
longues l'identification des auteurs sur
les réseaux sociaux difficiles et la
caractérisation des infractions
compliquées
depuis le début du dur ça se
durcissement de l'opposition au cada la
gendarmerie est pleinement mobilisée sur
la pacification de la commune elle
intervient sur chaque événement lié au
mouvement anti-cada même quand la police
municipale est déjà présente toutes les
plaines déposées en gendarmerie ou les
signalements de fées potentiellement
délictueux menacent injures appel à la
haine et maintenant de personnes
d'associations ou d'institutionnelles
dans cette affaire font l'objet d'un
traitement avant cette réunion du 10
février comme après les personnes
distribuées en détractes font l'objet
d'un contrôle et d'un relevé d'identité
à la date du 10 février 3 procédures
sont déjà en cours pour des faits de
diffamation ou d'injures parfois même
sans pleine forme
les représentants de parents d'élèves et
la directrice de l'école de la piraterie
sont auditionné dès le mois de janvier
et réunit en mairie le 27 janvier 2023
en présence du commandant de brigade qui
le rappelle ainsi qu'aux élus la
nécessité de prévenir plus
systématiquement et s'engueuler la
gendarmerie de tout fait lié à la
contestation du cadavre
la situation accro relative au cada
devenue une préoccupation essentielle de
l'État local est analysé à partir de
décembre 2022 en sous-préfecture à
chacune des réunions des forces de
sécurité toutes les deux semaines sous
ma présidence
à la suite de cette réunion nous
apprendrons ultérieurement que le maire
a défaut déposé formellement une plainte
a fait un signalement par écrit au
procureur de la République de Nantes le
15 février celui-ci fait état de
différents écrits tracts messages sur
les réseaux sociaux qui contestent avec
virulence l'implantation future du CADA
qui contiennent des propos violemment
immigrants
toutefois à ce moment-là aucune alerte
particulière relative à des menaces
immédiates portant son intégrité
physique des élus eux-mêmes de la
commune nous est parvenus
le samedi 25 février a lieu une nouvelle
manifestation initiée par le collectif
qui s'appelle désormais collectif de
préservation de la pierre athlée
l'après-midi devant la mairie déclarée
comme les précédentes celles-ci conduit
à l'organisation d'une manifestation du
collectif Brévinois solidaire déclarait
également mais le samedi matin
la présence annoncée du Bulletin du
train gauche dans une manifestation non
déclarée le samedi après-midi ainsi que
la présence de manifestants du trades
dans la manifestation du même après-midi
conduisent le service de l'État à
demander aux maires de prendre un arrêté
de police visant à bien séparer les
lieux de manifestation ce qu'il fait le
23 février en présence de mon collègue
sous préfet de permanence sur consigne
explicite du préfet de permanence
départementale et du général commandant
la région de gendarmerie trois unités de
force mobile seront nécessaires pour
protéger la mairie tenter d'éviter les
affrontements et séparer les ultras 900
manifestants procada sont présents le
matin dans le calme 380 manifestants
anticada seront présents l'après-midi
dont 80
militants du tragoche l'après-midi
également tente de forcer le barrage
policier et attaque violemment les
forces de l'ordre
la semaine qui commence le lundi 20 mars
2023 est une semaine particulièrement
difficile l'opposition sur la réforme
des retraites déjà bien installée au fil
des manifestations successives notamment
à Nantes et à Saint-Nazaire se durcit
dans la nuit du 20 au 21 mars je suis
avec les forces de l'ordre pour faire
libérer un appontement occupé afin de
permettre le débarquement de carburant
des signaux pipeline alimentant la
région la région parisienne le 22 mars
le pont de Saint-Nazaire est coupé la
plus grande partie de la journée et les
installations de signalisation dégradées
pour un coût estimé à 800 000 euros
le 23 mars une manifestation à
Saint-Nazaire vire les meute et la
sous-préfecture assiégée manque de peu
d’être envahi et parmi in extremises
grâce à des renforts venus en urgence de
Nantes des locaux municipaux nazairiens
sont dégradés tandis que la
manifestation à Nantes est également
extrêmement violente
le 22 mars en aoûté de médecine alors
que les gendarmes de la compagnie de
Pornic tiennent le milieu du pont pour
tenter d'empêcher son occupation totale
j'apprends que les véhicules du maire de
Saint-Brévin ont été incendié et une
partie de son domicile sur le terrain
duquel se trouve son cabinet médical
touché par les flammes le maire effectue
sa déposition auprès de la brigade de
recherche de Saint-Brevin et dès la fin
de celle-ci je l'appelle un peu avant
11h la conversation dure environ un
quart d'heure je le sens choqué mais
cohérent dans l'entretien
celui-ci porte bien évidemment sur les
faits mais également sur des hypothèses
concernant les auteurs je lui apporte
mon soutien le préfet appelle quant à
lui l'après-midi
à ce jour c'est incendie n'a pas fait
l'objet d'une quinconque revendication
et l'enquête confiée à la section de
recherche de Nantes n'a permis
d'identifier ni les auteurs ni les
motifs
dans les jours qui suivent la
gendarmerie met en place une protection
renforcée du domicile du maire dans des
dans les conditions où je rappellerai
par la suite dans le courrier que je lui
adresse le 11 avril en réponse à son
courrier du 7 avril inscription au
logiciel d'alerte prioritaire de son
domicile déclenchant une intervention
immédiate en cas d'alerte
intensification des contacts réguliers
avec le commandant de brigade et
patrouille régulière devant son domicile
le 24 mars je me rends à inauguration à
Pornic toujours après les faits beaucoup
d'élus des parlementaires sont présents
dans les conversations la situation à
Saint-Brévin est bien sûr évoquée ainsi
que la situation nationale sur la
réforme contrairement à ce que je
pensais les communautés assez proches le
maire de Saint-Brevin n'est pas présent
les manifestations violentes se
poursuivent au cours des semaines
suivantes à raison d'environ une par
semaine jusqu'au 1er mai
le 28 mars est organisé une réunion à la
demande du commandant de compagnie en
présence de l'agent de la gendarmerie du
maire et de plusieurs élus sur la
question de leur sécurité faisant suite
aux propos tenues dans la presse sur le
manque de soutien de l'État le point est
fait avec le maire sur les procédures en
cours pour les diverses plaintes
signalement et fait constater c'est être
c'est à cette occasion que Monsieur
Mores évoque des courriers aussi plus
tôt et mentionnés dans son courrier au
procureur de Nantes le 15 février les
gendarmes lui ont demandé de
communication
le vendredi 7 avril je reçois le matin
adressé par son directeur de cabinet un
courriel contenant une lettre du maire
celui-ci demande une protection
mentionnant par comparaison celle dont
bénéficie le maire de Bélâbre dans
l'Indre à Nantes l'après-midi pour une
réunion je l'évoque avec le préfet nous
convenons des termes de la réponse que
je partage avec le commandant de
compagnie et que je lui adresse et que
l'adresse au maire dès le mardi 11 avril
le lundi étant le lundi de Pâques
en quittant Nantes je me rends à une
réunion dans la commune du Pouliguen
organisé à l'initiative de vos collègues
présents du département de
Loire-Atlantique sur la protection des
élus je dois intervenir au cours d'une
table ronde à laquelle le maire de
Saint-Brevin doit témoigner ce qui
constitue une occasion d'évoquer
oralement son courrier en retard du fait
de nombreux embouteillages en cette
veille de long week-end entre Nantes et
Le Pouliguen j'arrive alors que la table
ronde a déjà commencé j'entends alors le
maire de Saint-Brevin dans son
témoignage se plaindre du manteau du
manque de soutien de l'État en général
et de moi-même en particulier je dois
intervenir en dernier après d'autres
témoignages dont celui du général
commandant la région de gendarmerie au
moment où je prends mon tour le micro
monsieur Mores invoquant une obligation
quitte la réunion ce sera la dernière
fois où je le verrai avant qu'il envoie
sa lettre de démission
dans mon courrier du 11 avril en réponse
à sa lettre du 7 avril après lui avoir
indiqué qu'il disposait déjà de la même
protection que celle du maire de Bélâbre
que je rappelle que je lui rappelle je
lui indique une évaluation de
l'évolution de la menace sur lui-même et
sa famille va être réactualisée au vu de
sa demande par la gendarmerie en effet
avant toute demande de ce type une
évaluation doit permettre de
caractériser le danger encouru releva
relevant d'informations
voire judiciaire dans les enquêtes en
cours
la compagnie gendarmerie le relance par
courriel du 15 avril pour une rencontre
dans le cadre de sa protection et de
celle de son domicile en particulier un
diagnostic de la cellule de protection
technique contre la malveillance déjà
proposé oralement après l'incendie du 22
mars
cette mesure suppose d'abord suppose
l'accord express de la personne
concernée en l'absence de réponse
monsieur Morez et relancé oralement par
le commandant de compagnie le 6 mai à
une exposition temporaire au musée de la
Marine de Saint-Brévin
une nouvelle manifestation a lieu le
samedi 29 avril à Saint-Brévin après les
contacts entre l'adjoint la sécurité et
la gendarmerie le mardi 25 avril le
maire prend un arrêté de police assez
semblable à celui pris à l'occasion de
la manifestation du 25 février qui
réglemente la manifestation sans
l'interdire je suis présent conformément
consigne du préfet toute la journée avec
le procureur de la République le Général
de gendarmerie et l'adjoint à la
sécurité deux unités de force mobile
sont mobilisées pour assurer la
protection de la mairie comme le 25
février et séparé la manifestation
déclarée du collectif de la pierre
atelier de celle de militants du train
gauche
le collectif de Brévinois Solidaires a
également prévu une manifestation mais
sous forme de pose de première pierre
devant le site du futur le site du futur
cada assez éloigné de la mairie pour
éviter tout risque de contact avec le
collectif anticada je salue à cet égard
leur sens de responsabilité
quelques affrontements très bref on lui
en ville lorsque les ultras des deux
camps se rencontrent très vite séparés
par les forces de l'ordre une voiture
appartenant manifestement un opposant au
cada
identifié par la présence de banderolles
et brûlée par le tragoche devant la
mairie environ 240 manifestants anticada
sont présents les forces de l'ordre qui
font barrage sont agressés à plusieurs
reprises par le dragon 300 personnes qui
tentent de parvenir devant la mairie
pour affronter les manifestants du
collectif eux-mêmes au nombre d'un peu
plus d'une centaine soutenus par une
centaine d'ultra-droite
depuis cette date et sur cette affaire
seuls quelques tags des deux camps ont
été constatés dans la ville
à chaque étape de ce dossier et
particulièrement que depuis la situation
c'est fortement durci c'est-à-dire
depuis la toute fin de l'année 2022 les
services de l'État chacun dans leur rôle
et préfets les sous-préfet dans leur
mission respective les forces de l'ordre
tout particulièrement la gendarmerie
départementale l'opérateur désigné pour
gérer le dossier ont été constamment
présent
on consacré énormément de temps et
d'énergie à la gestion de cette affaire
à toutes les étapes il a été rappelé
qu'il s'agissait d'un sujet de la
compétence de l'État porté par l'État
local dans lequel celui-ci s'est
constamment investi
la commune en général assez tranquille
de Saint-Brévin à certes été secoué par
cette affaire mais elle n'a jamais été
laissée seule dans les difficultés comme
comme démontre cette exposé un peu long
mais nécessaire pour mesurer
l'investissement des autorités étatiques
je vous remercie
si Monsieur le Préfet merci à vous deux
pour
exposer extrêmement complet et Monsieur
Usain Borgia demander la parole mais
peut-être que nous rapporteurs merci
beaucoup monsieur le président
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Préfet merci
beaucoup monsieur le sous-préfet je
voulais vous poser trois ou quatre
questions très factuelles la première
concernant le nombre de réunions
publiques organisée dans la commune
entre le 11 mars 2021 au cours de
laquelle cette date vous avez annoncé le
nouveau projet de cada pouvez-vous nous
dire monsieur le sous-préfet à combien
de réunions publiques avez-vous
participé aux côtés de Monsieur le Maire
de Saint-Brévin deuxième question quelle
forme a pris votre soutien au maire de
Saint-Brévin vous nous avez parlé
d'appels téléphoniques pouvez-vous nous
indiquer si l'un et l'autre ou l'un ou
l'autre est allé dans la commune de
Saint-Brévin après l'incendie qui a
touché le domicile le cabinet médical et
les véhicules du maire de Saint-Brevin
le son de sa famille
avant dernière question monsieur le
sous-préfet a quelle régularité à quelle
fréquence avez-vous informé Monsieur le
Préfet de l'évolution de la situation à
Saint-Brévin
Monsieur le Préfet pour votre part à
quelle fréquence à quel régularité si
vous l'avez fait avez-vous informé le
ministre de l'intérieur des faits
survenu à Saint-Brevin naturellement je
parle des faits antérieurs à l'incendie
et dernière question quels enseignements
l'un et l'autre tirez-vous des faits
survenus à Saint-Brévin pour hier pour
aujourd'hui et surtout pour demain merci
Monsieur Bourget monsieur Mathieu
d'Arnaud qui rapporte de la mission la
présidente peut-être je sais pas
oui
en complément des questions que notre
collègue Bourgier vient de poser moi il
y a deux sujets qui ont été évoqués lors
de notre
précédent réunion et audition du maire
de Saint-Brévin la première remarque
porte et vous avez évoqué le sujet des
tracts sont les qualifier
des tracts qui selon les dires du du
maire était suffisamment choquant voire
abject pour qu'il fasse l'objet
nous semble-t-il de poursuites et je
voudrais savoir si
les poursuites que vous avez évoquées
font notamment écho et références assez
assez tracts qui nous avait été décrit
de façon assez précise par le maire
la seconde
remarque et dernière remarques pour moi
aussi une interrogation vous avez évoqué
monsieur le sous-préfet à plusieurs
reprises la réévaluation de la menace et
des risques qui pesaient sur les élus et
sur le maire en particulier
je trouve qu'il y a un nombre de
faisceaux et d'éléments qui me semblent
être largement constitutif d'une d'une
menace sur le maire notamment
eugar aux différentes manifestations à
la forme compris dans le temps c'est
c'est manifestations et
au dire de ce que le préfet vous même
avez dit d'une certaine forme de
violence répétée dont on pouvait
largement imaginer qu'elle puisse à un
moment donné déboucher sur
une violence à l'endroit du maire de de
Saint-Brevin et ma remarque
fait suite à ce que vous avez affirmé
parce qu'il semble quand même que la
réévaluation soit relativement tardive
vous avez parlé du mois du mois d'avril
c'est-à-dire plusieurs jours après que
les événements et notamment l'incendie
ce soit ce soit produit je voudrais
savoir à partir de quel élément vous
considérez et quand je dis vous c'est
bien sûr préfet sous préfet mais aussi
le commandant puisque vous avez parlé du
commandant de gendarmerie pour
considérer qu'il y a nécessité à avoir
je veux dire une protection qui soit
rapprochée et
j'ajouterai à cette question que faut-il
entendre par protection rapprochée parce
que nous avons toutes et tous ici
étaient à un moment donné appelé leur de
manifestations des mois ou des années
précédentes par des préfets et sous
préfets pour faire état vous l'avez
rappelé dans votre propos introductif
Monsieur le Préfet de potentiel
menace ou exposition à des à des faits
de violence
quelle forme prend cette cette
protection rapprochée des élus je vous
remercier merci Monsieur Darnaud madame
de La Gontrie
merci monsieur le président
je crois que ce qui nous ce qui nous
interroge c'est au fond qu'elle a été le
comportement de l'État entre le mois
d'octobre 2022 début des tensions
début des manifestations début des
campagnes de stilité y compris sur les
réseaux sociaux
y compris sur le site ripos laïque
octobre puis décembre 2022 et premier
courrier 23 janvier 2023 ou le maire
vous écrit Monsieur le Préfet fait tas
de menaces et demande votre soutien
quelle réponse avez-vous apporté est-il
exact que une réunion s'est tenue
sous-préfet gendarmerie au cours duquel
il a été en quelque sorte banalisé les
événements qui pouvaient se manifester
le conseil municipal ensuite été envahi
des tracts haineux ont été distribués le
15 février le parquet a été saisi il n'y
a semble-t-il pas eu de réponse puis le
22 mars l'attentat criminel
7 avril demande de protection
25 avril environ je n'ai pas la date
précise demande d'interdiction d'une
manifestation qui a été refusée tout
cela amené à l'envoi de lettre de
démission il serait très utile que nous
sachions concrètement ce que vous avez
fait lorsque incontestablement la
tension montait
les propos les menaces devenaient de
plus en plus caractérisées évidemment
avec l'attentat criminel tel que c'est
qualifié par le maire
et voilà concrètement qu'avez-vous fait
pour protéger accompagner et quelle
réponse avez-vous donné aux maires
lorsqu'il vous sollicitait merci Madame
alors madame Marie scarer qui est de la
commission des lois mais également
présente de la mission
merci pour pour ces éléments que vous
avez pu nous apporter alors j'ai
beaucoup de questions qui ont déjà été
posées sur Joe mes collègues sur sur la
question de l'autorisation de la
manifestation puisque le maire vous a
demandé d'interdire cette manifestation
sur sur quel motif vous avez
répondu négativement à sa demande
sur vous avez dit aussi sur les mesures
prises
par la gendarmerie dès l'incendie dès la
suite de l'incendie vous avez
dit que la gendarmerie avait mis des
prix des mesures pour la protection du
maire si vous pouvez nous les nous les
détailler
la demande de protection rapprochée
effectivement on a un petit
des délais d'attente de réponse au maire
à qui n'ont pas été satisfait et un
certain moment quel lien avez-vous eu
avec le procureur sur le dossier de
sambrevin est-ce que la justice a été
saisie est-ce que vous avez eu des
discussions avec avec le procureur sur
ces sujets merci madame Monsieur Didier
marie puis madame bellerault merci
monsieur le Président quelques questions
tout d'abord
sur le projet de cada
dès lors que le projet a été contesté
pourquoi les services de l'État ne sont
pas associés systématiquement à
l'opérateur pour toutes les réunions
publiques qui ont pu avoir lieu et
avez-vous déclenché des réunions
publiques spécifiques pour tenter
d'informer
mieux qu'une l'était
les habitants de Saint-Brévin
deuxième question
en écho un peu ce que disait Matthieu
Darnaud
quelle est la nature des mesures de
sécurité qui ont été mises en oeuvre
après l'incendie et de quel Arsenal
disposez-vous de façon plus générale
pour faire face à une demande de
protection d'un élu
troisièmement le maire nous a indiqué
lors de son audition que la gendarmerie
vous-même sous le sous-préfet et les
services de l'État ne pouvaient
enregistrer de plein tout l'amener à
enregistrer à déposer plainte ou
interdire des manifestations au nom de
la liberté d'expression est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire ce qu'il en était
lorsque ces propos ont pu être tenus et
si effectivement le maire nous a bien
dit cela
merci Monsieur Marie Madame belureau
Monsieur kerou Merci monsieur le
Président merci pour ces explications
permettez-moi d'abord de commencer
puisque vous l'avez mentionné
d'adresser évidemment aussi mes pensées
au maire de Bélâbre qui se trouve être
dans le département de l'Indre et
Laurent Laroche et qui a lui aussi
une installation de Cana en vue et eu
des menaces sur lui et sa famille et a
fait l'objet aussi de beaucoup
d'intimidation et a pu aussi témoigner
de cette de cette violence
j'aimerais savoir puisqu'en fait cette
décision relève de l'État d'installer ou
non un cada dans une commune comment en
fait sont vraiment organisés ces
décisions et surtout est-ce que vous
avez au niveau central auprès de
l'administration centrale auprès
éventuellement des cabinets je ne sais
pas
une circulaire une méthodologie
vis-à-vis de ces installations parce
qu'en effet je rebondis un peu ce qui
vient d'être dit une fois décidé est-ce
que il ne revient pas aussi à
l'administration de bien accompagner
cette communication sur l'installation
dans une commune parce que on constate
et on entend souvent que ben en fait la
commune se trouve à gérer l'installation
en termes de communication auprès de sa
population
et donc peut-être totalement démunie
face à une montée en puissance de
l'hostilité de personnes qui ne
souhaitent pas le cette installation
donc est-ce qu'en fait il y a un moment
où il y a une enfin une information au
niveau central une des échanges aussi
également entre les communes qui sont et
vos collègues qui sont aussi dans une
situation ou un cadas s'installe et
est-ce que vous échangez entre vous pour
avoir une pratique cohérente et surtout
une vraie méthode d'accompagnement des
élus dans ces situations
difficiles et voir même dramatique merci
merci Alain monsieur Kero je suis
monsieur
joelgari ou pas merci monsieur le
Président
de questions assez assez brève la
première c'est on s'est en général que
l'installation de de cada peut poser des
difficultés c'est récurrents mais il y a
d'autant moins de difficultés que
l'implication des services de l'État a
été a été forte alors pour faire simple
je pense par exemple à des manifestants
qui savent qui ont pu avoir lieu dans
d'autres départements comme l'Auvergne
et qui en fait ont été inversés qui font
que le CADA dans le temps a été
particulièrement bien intégré donc ma
question est toute simple comment vous
expliquer
l'échec de se transfert de cadastre
spécifiquement sur la commune de
Saint-Brevin ce que vous considérez que
c'est un échec collectif un échec
d'implication des services de l'État
comment vous referiez d'une certaine
façon cette implantation la deuxième
question monsieur le sous-préfet vous
parliez et je reviens à ce que disait
mon collègue
usen Bourgy vous vous parliez d'une
inauguration à laquelle vous étiez allé
et vous vous étonniez tout à l'heure de
ne pas avoir vu le maire de de
Saint-Brevin qui n'était pas à cette
inauguration même si vous avez parlé du
sujet avec les élus qui étaient présents
c'est assez c'est assez étonnant de
s'attendre à des inaugurations et donc
la question c'est plutôt de savoir donc
effectivement quels ont été la fréquence
de de vos échanges avec le maire de
Saint-Brévin pour
dans l'accompagnement j'allais dire que
vous avez pu faire de
cette affaire je vous remercie merci
Monsieur kerouche Madame Gatel
merci beaucoup monsieur merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président le président de la
commission des lois aladines nous sommes
là pour comprendre et surtout tirer les
leçons de cette affaire pour prévenir et
empêcher et moi j'aurais une double
question sur la manière dont ce projet
de réimplantation de cada était
effectivement géré mes collègues Blondy
les cadavres sont souvent des sujets un
peu difficiles même si je reconnais que
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins apparemment il y
avait pas eu de question et pas
d'interrogations et pas de manifestation
alors même qu'un cada est installé
depuis longtemps mais est-ce qu'il y a
eu à un moment ce qu'on appelle nous une
étude d'impact n'appréciation des
risques des risques de débordement qui
pouvaient arriver est-ce qu'il y a eu
effectivement constitution une sorte de
comité de pilotage où il y avait à la
fois l'état l'opérateur auquel l'État
déléguer la réalisation de ce cada des
élus et moi je voudrais aussi parler de
l'éducation nationale pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que le nouveau site choisi
est à proximité d'une école et on sait
que tout installation auprès d'une école
soulève des tas de questions et des tas
de peur et qu'il faut savoir les traiter
pour éviter que tout cela ne s'aggrave
et j'ai cru comprendre que la directrice
de l'école avait été aussi l'objet de
menaces et donc comment accompagne-t-on
les parents d'élèves enfin comment
évitons que ce soit un foyer de question
d'interrogations et deuxième élément
suite à cette première appréciation de
risque qui a dû avoir lieu est arrivé
à calaq en Bretagne un événement qui
n'est pas anodin puisqu'il y a eu un
projet par une association
d'installation on va dire d'un cada
privé or on a vu à cette occasion les
choses devenir l'objet
instrumentalisation
politiqueienne assez conséquente assez
effrayante et que est-ce qu'a un moment
il n'y a pas eu une évaluation du risque
de contamination et d'exportation vers
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins de la situation de
Kalak qui dégénérait et on sait que
apparemment parmi les manifestants
d'extrême droite qui sont venus à Cala
qui ceux qui instrumentalisaient des
craintes et des peurs il y avait
semble-t-il un des organisateurs de ou à
membres actif des manifestations qui
s'étaient tenues à Calac sur le même
sujet merci
président
proche du maire de Saint-Brévin
évidemment je vis très mal le fait qu'il
était amené jusqu'à démissionner
et je suis bien sûr avec beaucoup
d'attention cette cette audition parce
que je pense qu'effectivement il est
important de qu'on puisse comprendre
comment on peut en arriver là
moi je sais Monsieur préfet puisque vous
êtes en place depuis le 30 janvier
combien vous êtes disponible et puis
j'ai eu l'occasion de croiser j'ai
calculé 27 fois sur le terrain en trois
mois donc c'est quand même pas rien
monsieur je préfère vous aviez répondu à
la à mon appel lorsque le 7 avril je
vais organiser cette réunion avec les
élus gloires Atlantiques et ce qui
ressortait en votre présence de cette
réunion auquel a porté son témoignage
Yannick Morez ce qui ressortait c'était
ce sentiment d'impunité et le fait que
les élus qui étaient présents et qui
faisait part de leur témoignage
ressentait une frustration du fait que
les plaintes qui étaient déposées
étaient donnés sans suite
et cette frustration est lourde de
conséquences et ma porte elle m'amène à
cette question que s'est-il passé à
partir de courrier quatadé assez vous
l'avez rappelé le 15 février au
procureur de la République est-ce qu'il
y a eu une enquête préalable qui a été
engagée est-ce qu'on a pris toutes les
mesures pour essayer de trouver quels
étaient les auteurs de ces menaces parce
que je pense que la meilleure des
préventions c'est quand même de mettre
fin la touriste de d'accentuation d'un
événement de cette nature si on est face
à des menaces et bien il faut bien
évidemment rechercher les auteurs le
plus vite possible et éviter qu'ils
aillent encore au-delà de ce qu'ils ont
promis de faire et que nous espérons
bien évidemment qu'il ne fasse pas en
l'occurrence malheureusement le pur est
arrivé
merci chers
merci monsieur le président
participer comme je pense là totalité
des collègues ici présents à l'audition
du maire de Saint-Brévin
je vous ai écouté naturellement aussi
très longuement ce soir il y a au moins
un élément sur lequel on va être
d'accord c'est que
votre vision respective de la
chronologie de la faire qui m'a l'air
d'ailleurs d'être plutôt proche en
termes de de des différentes étapes
concernées à montrer la longueur la
durée de cette de cette montée
[Musique]
de l'affaire jusqu'où jour d'aujourd'hui
enfin jusqu'à cette cette décision du
maire de Saint-Brevin démissionné dans
les conditions que l'on connaît
tout au long de cette durée on a bien vu
que différents partenaires ont été
mobilisés
je note tout particulièrement celle de
l'opérateur l'opérateur donc vous dites
qu'il était partout etc
l'opérateur est en censé représenter
l'état je suis pas sûr que spécialement
il fut toujours entre guillemets
apprécie en tant que tel même peut-être
par le conseil municipal voire peut-être
par le maire d'autres opérateurs nous
ont vous l'avez dit nous ont
effectivement
été signalé par Monsieur le Maire de
Saint-Brévin la gendarmerie
[Musique]
sur sollicitations du sous-préfet etc
mais ma question elle va être très
direct pour avoir été maire élu local
plus de décennies comme certainement un
certain nombre de collègues ici
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que le
rôle de l'État compte tenu de la
justement de la durée de cette affaire
dans le temps aurait été d'être
humainement à côté humainement à côté de
ce maire je répète j'étais à l'audition
moi j'ai écouté un maire vraiment
perturbé vraiment perturbé et je me
mettais à sa place et je me disais mais
où est le préfet où est le sous-préfet
dans tout ce qu'il dit
je répète certes l'opérateur était
peut-être là mais pour avoir été maire
très franchement je m'adresse aux sous
préfet je m'adresse au préfet en disant
venez à mon secours aidez-moi voilà et
excus ez moi de vous le dire aussi
clairement que ça j'ai pas eu le
sentiment et vous venez nous dire que
la personne du préfère respectivement du
sous-préfet était perçus en tant que tel
suffisamment par Monsieur le Maire de
Saint-Brevin j'aimerais bien vous
écouter à cet égard si et Monsieur bonne
Carrère
merci monsieur le Président l'accueil
des migrants est un sujet extrêmement
difficile et notre commission des lois
de par ces attributions
est assez amenée à suivre ces types de
sujets nous savons aussi que vous avez
des instructions ministérielles pour
pouvoir accueillir à travers l'ensemble
des territoires français
les migrants pour éviter ce qu'il y a de
bon sens qui est une concentration
excessive en Île-de-France en
Seine-Saint-Denis et à Paris en
particulier
ce qui est une manière pour moi de vous
dire que des saints brévin-les-pins nous
en avons malheureusement un certain
nombre peut-être pas dans les
conséquences dramatiques vis-à-vis du
maire bien entendu mais madame Gatel
cité la commune de Callac on vit dans la
presse madame bellurault faisait
référence à notre site sur son
département et je pourrais
éventuellement vous en donner d'autres
dans d'autres départements en
particulier dans celui que je représente
donc ma première question monsieur
préfet monsieur monsieur préfet c'est
est-ce que vous avez d'autres projets
sur le département de Loire-Atlantique
est-ce qu'en particulier non non il y a
pas d'ironie dans tout ceci mais est-ce
que par exemple
il y a une demande de d'installation
d'un cada en diffus ce qui est quand
même aujourd'hui ce que nous voyons
apparaître être recommandé sur nos
différents départements ou est-ce
qu'avec ce exclusivement le sujet de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins deuxième et ma
deuxième question porte sur le fait de
savoir si vous avez monsieur préfet
monsieur sous-préfet des sortes de de
capteurs qui vous aurait permis de mieux
mesurer le niveau de difficulté le
désarroi parce que nous sommes quand
même devant un sujet qui était public le
hasard de la vie veulent que
dans le cadre dans des bas organisés sur
Public Sénat sur les sujets migratoires
il y a eu un reportage qui a été fait
sur Saint-Brevin-les-Pins et nous avons
eu une intervention directe d'une
habitante de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins dont
la virulence
m'a quand même frappé je vais regarder à
ce moment-là un petit peu ce qui se
disait dans la presse on voyait bien que
les la situation à Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
était très connue localement je suis
également frappé c'est toujours l'idée
de capteur par le fait que Monsieur le
Maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins était
également président de
l'intercommunalité je ne fais pas
hiérarchie entre les mères mais
généralement un président interco a une
relation assez directe avec son
sous-préfet arrondissement ou avec son
bref et j'ai entendu tout à l'heure que
l'adjoint à la sécurité qui gérait le
dossier au quotidien est également
conseillé départemental ça veut dire que
il y a aussi un relais possible à
travers le département les
parlementaires sont là ma question est
donc simplement la suivante est-ce que
vous n'avez pas eu l'un et l'autre
malgré l'importance de vos
responsabilités et le contexte que vous
avez rappelé monsieur préfiant préambule
vous n'avez pas eu de
personnes ou à travers la gendarmerie on
pourra avoir de multiples qui vous est
dit faites attention il y a qu'un
problème particulier à Saint-Brévin le
maire étant difficulté son conseil
municipal et sous pression et nous
savons bien que au-delà de des
manifestations publiques il y a la
pression du quotidien il y a la pression
que subit un maire médecin généraliste
quand il est interpellé par sa
population est-ce que vous n'avez pas eu
un petit peu plus de capteurs qui vous
aurait permis de mieux apprendre de
cette situation merci
merci bien écoutez monsieur les préfets
c'était la dernière série dernière
intervention je vous laisse désormais la
parole dans l'ordre que vous souhaiterez
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
peut-être
on va compléter nos propos avec le
sous-préfet et on va essayer évidemment
de répondre exhaustivement à toute vos
questionnements peut-être d'abord sur
une question qui est revenue à deux
reprises sur l'interdiction de
manifestation et notamment la demande je
vous confirme que j'ai été destinataire
d'un courriel en date du 17 avril de
Monsieur le Maire de Saint-Brevin me
demandant de d'interdire la
manifestation programmée le 29 avril
donc c'est un courriel du 17 avril
que j'ai ici et qui insiste notamment
sur sur trois points
c'est de manière générale que la ville
effectivement ne soit plus lieu
d'expression de haine tout ça ce qui est
le cas notamment lors des manifestations
précédentes le second point qui
évidemment fondamental c'est la risque
de risque pardon de commission de
troubles à l'ordre public et le
troisième point c'est aussi les
conséquences économiques puisque le 29
était le week-end du 1er mai donc un
week-end notamment pour une ville et une
station balnéaire particulièrement
attractive
évidemment j'ai comme pour toute
manifestation d'ailleurs mais encore
plus là fait procéder une analyse de mes
services sur j'allais dire la
possibilité je rappelle enfin vous le
savez mieux quiconque le principe et la
liberté de manifestation et
l'interdiction doit être l'exception
on interdiction de l'exception elle est
d'ailleurs fondée sur l'article L
211 4 pour tirer 4 du Code de sécurité
intérieure
au vu de l'analyse de mes services il y
avait effectivement potentiellement à
partir du moment où il y a une contre
manifestation des risques de trou noir
de troubles à l'ordre public mais je
rappelle que les conditions
d'interdiction c'est elles sont assez
strictement définies par le par le code
c'est à la fois le risque de troubles à
leur public le fait qu'on ne puisse pas
qu'on ne puisse pas des les contrôler
et et l'incapacité entre guillemets de
diffère face en matière de dispositif
l'analyse qui a été faite par mes
services auquel je souscris que donc
c'est sur le fond c'est qu'on n'était
pas dans un cadre là permettant
légalement d'arrêter la manifestation à
forti parce qu'elle avait été déclarée
parce que elle avait été déclarée par un
collectif auquel sa joignait il est vrai
des militants qui venaient de
l'extérieur je l'ai dit dans mon propos
à la fois extérieur à la commune et
extérieure au département et que en
procédure en plus une telle interdiction
relevée et c'est pour ça que je j'ai pas
j'ai pas saisi de merde au-dessus du
Code Général des Collectivités
Territoriales lorsqu'il n'y a pas de
police d'État c'est l'autorité de police
qui peut autoriser ou interdire une
manifestation en l'espèce sur le
territoire d'une salle commune c'est
l'autorité municipale et j'ai préféré
assumer la non-interdiction au niveau de
l'État puisque pour l'apprendre au-delà
même du fond c'est de ceux de solliciter
Monsieur le Maire de prendre sous forme
de mise en demeure au titre du CGCT
d'une mise en demeure pour interdire la
manifestation sur des bases dont
l'analyse ne me semblait pas fonder en
droit en plus j'aurais dû le mettre en
demeure et le cas échéant me substituer
si ne recréerait pas assez ne faisait
pas droit à cette mise en demeure sa
raison pour laquelle j'ai préféré
assumer au niveau de l'État la non
interdiction de cette manifestation et
en revanche de prendre toutes les
mesures y compris un articulation avec
la mairie parce qu'elle a fait l'objet
d'une préparation le 25 avril juste dans
quelques jours avant de prendre les
mesures y compris d'arrêter de périmètre
pour pouvoir l'organiser la gérer en
matière d'ordre public
sur l'information du cabinet évidemment
l'information du cabinet a été a été
constante notamment vous le savez à
partir du moment où on mobilise des
forces en termes de renfort on rencontre
du las de l'utilisation de ses forces
comme pour toute manifestation donc
l'information de
notamment de des instances parisiennes
de ces fêtes sur
enfin en direct à l'issue de chacune des
en particulier de chacune des deux
manifestations et des emplois et de
l'usage de la force qui a été plus
significative d'ailleurs le 29 avril que
le 25 février il y a pas eu d'usage
d'usage de moyens lacrymogènes sur les
mesures de sécurité
excusez-moi
alors pas de signalement autre que le
compte-rendu
de la manifestation notamment du 25
février
et
de 25 février et
il n'y a pas une manette non
oui pardon j'ai pas forcément
excusez-moi
de la période depuis que je suis en
poste en tout cas et après oui il y a eu
des sous préfet compléter ou complétera
après
chaque manifestation significative a
fait l'objet d'un compte-rendu à Paris
celle du 11 décembre et celle du
25 février et puis évidemment celle du
29 avril et pour compléter le propos
notamment de la période où je suis en
poste sur le Loire-Atlantique on a fait
aussi une information
factuelle comment on fait habituellement
lorsqu'il y est la commission de
l'incendie le 22 mars
sur les mesures de sécurité justement
prises après le 22 mars
on en a on les a cités je vais les
rappeler elles ont d'ailleurs été
consolidées dans un ce qu'on appelle
enfin ce que les gendarmes appellent un
ordre de conduite adressé à l'ensemble
des militaires pour préciser les choses
à un ordre de conduite qui date du 25
mars 2022
ces mesures de renforcement ont porté à
la fois sur la personne du maire mais
également sur la personne de 6 adjoints
de la mairie de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
elles ont d'abord
consisté en passage systématique de
toutes les patrouilles soit au moins
quatre fois par jour devant le domicile
du maire et devant le domicile des
adjoints au-delà des patrouilles et des
sites qui étaient déjà en surveillance
l'inscription de leur domicile au
fichiers SIP de la gendarmerie qui
permet notamment lorsque il y a un appel
du 17 de pouvoir identifier
informatiquement l'origine de l'appel et
un signalement spécifique même si
l'ensemble des élus notamment le maire
des gendarmes et le commandant de
compagnie comme le commandant de brigade
avait donné leur portable et puis c'est
le renforcement on l'a dit des contacts
réguliers qui se traduit par
l'organisation d'un certain nombre de
réunions dédiés à la sécurité notamment
celle du vin du 28 mars je l'ai dit donc
ça c'est point on fait l'objet d'une
formalisation dans un dans un ordre
opérationnel de la gendarmerie pour que
l'ensemble de ces de ces préconisations
puissent se dérouler
sur peut-être le sentiment d'impunité
c'est vrai que je crois que c'est le
sénateur griot qui le mentionner
on peut au cours des visites des
contacts être confrontés à ça je crois
que en tout cas moi à chaque fois et
depuis mon arrivée évidemment
Loire-Atlantique à chaque fois qu'il y a
un sujet de cette nature là je j'incite
je j'enjoins si j'ose dire entre
guillemets les personnes meurent ou
d'autres d'ailleurs ça vaut aussi pour
les fonctionnaires par exemple des
forces de sécurité à déposer plainte à
déposer plainte pour que les choses
puissent être judiciarisées et pour
qu'une réponse pénale puisse le cas
échéant être apporté lorsque la
qualification des faits est avérée et
fait l'objet d'une enquête donc en tout
cas d'un point de vue de l'État
administratif sachez que les consignes
et que je donne à chacun de mes de mes
collaborateurs c'est évidemment
d'inciter
chaque personne qui a semble-t-il ou à
l'impression ou a le sentiment ou fait
l'objet de évidemment encore plus de
menaces de déposer plein je le fais
systématiquement et singulièrement
auprès des élus
après je pense que ça interroge et je le
dis c'est vrai qu'il faut je disais dans
mon propos toujours essayer de voir
comment on pourrait faire mieux comment
on aurait pu faire mieux aussi sur ce
type de situation et je crois que un des
sujets qui a été abordé c'est c'est des
décisions je pense qu'on peut être mise
en place et dire sans changement de
texte forcément mais à l'échelle
territoriale vous savez qu'on a un
état-major de sécurité qui réunit à la
fois les parquets sachant qu'en
Loire-Atlantique on en a deux
de parquet les parquets l'ensemble des
services
issus des forces de l'ordre et
l'ensemble du corps préfectoral cet
état-major de sécurité se tient tous les
deux mois et j'ai indiqué que je
souhaitais maintenant systématiquement
en fait on est un point parce que ça
permet d'avoir l'ensemble des autorités
qui sont concernées on est un point
inscrit à l'heure de jour de cet
état-major sur l'état des enfin les
procédures déposées ça que les relève de
l'autorité judiciaire l'état des menaces
et le cas échéant l'évaluation de la
menace ou la révélation de la menace
parce qu'on a tous les services
entre guillemets sous la main je pense
que c'est un élément justement pour
permettre aussi de rendre compte par le
biais des associations d'élus ou
évidemment en individuel mais c'est une
matière judiciaire donc c'est pas le
sous-préfet ou l'autorité administrative
qui peut en rendre compte de l'état
d'avancement en matière judiciaire mais
c'est au moins une manière d'avoir un je
pense vraiment à une vision globale des
sujets y compris d'en rendre compte et
de le partager en particulier que les
associations d'élus à charge ensuite
pour les services d'enquête sous le
contrôle et sous l'autorité de
l'autorité judiciaire d'être tenu
informé de des enquêtes qui les
concernent à titre à titre individuel
sur les capteurs que mentionnés sur le
sénateur
moi je l'ai dit je partir au moment où
le résultat c'est la démission d'un
maire forcément il faut qu'on
s'interroge il faut voir si les choses
peuvent être améliorées alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a pas eu de capteurs et compris
je faisais mon enfin je l'ai dit je suis
allé à la rencontre de tous les élus de
tous les parlementaires des présents
d'associations j'ai fait des rencontres
avec l'ensemble des mers sous forme de
webinaire et
enfin je n'ai pas de voilà c'était aussi
ça peut être aussi des capteurs au-delà
des services de l'État bien sûr et des
services de renseignement et je les dis
sur les services de renseignement c'est
vrai que c'est d'où l'utilité l'absolu
nécessité de judiciariser d'ailleurs
sous forme de dépôt de plainte ou de
signalement au parquet pour pouvoir
mais simplement j'indique que d'un point
de vue administratif renseignement
administratif des services de
renseignement administratif j'ai pas eu
de on n'a pas eu de remonter spécifique
sur de menaces portant sur l'intégrité
du maire et en revanche je vous confirme
que dans le cadre de tous ces entretiens
en fait de de présentation
il n'y a pas forcément il y a pas
d'éléments particuliers qui me sont
venus pour autant pour autant c'est
évidemment une situation qui est pas
satisfaisante je le dis et je alors
c'est rétrospectivement évidemment mais
je le dis c'est vrai que
ce que j'avais dit c'est on n'était pas
dans ce contexte là etc
très prenant très très je veux dire très
engageant y compris sur des dimensions
d'ordre public mon réflexe aurait été
d'aller voir la mer
parce que ça aurait été le meilleur
moyen de percevoir aussi en direct
les difficultés
du maire de son entourage d'anticiper
aussi je le dis je n'ai pas anticipé sa
volonté de démission
parce que j'ai pas eu le l'opportunité
la possibilité dans le cadre de ce de
ces contraintes de l'État local au
moment où ça s'est situé et c'est pas
non plus j'ai eu des échanges et
notamment le jour même de l'incendie ou
je vais indiquer à sa totale disposition
c'est vrai que j'ai pas non plus été re
sollicité mais je voilà c'est évidemment
pas satisfaisant c'est évidemment je
l'ai dit quelque chose une situation qui
est une situation qui est tout sauf
anodine qui peut pas laisser indifférent
elle me laisse pas indifférent et c'est
vrai que rétrospectivement je me suis me
disais que si j'avais plus de percevoir
en direct
ces difficultés ces éléments ça m'aurait
permis d'abord d'anticiper la démission
et puis voilà de pouvoir approfondir les
choses avec le maire
sur le rôle de l'État mais j'ai répondu
je crois dans dans mon propos je
maintiens qu'on a été attentif
manifestement là aussi pas suffisamment
ça n'a pas été suffisamment ressenti
comme tel par Monsieur le Maire et ça je
le respecte
ce ressenti mais on a été je crois en
tout cas j'ai été attentif par les
échanges que les deux échanges directs
que j'ai eu avec lui par cette volonté
de soutenir y compris dans le cas de la
Constitution et du montage d'un dossier
de cada compliqué vous lui avez souligné
un certain nombre d'entre vous notamment
au long cours et pour répondre très
précisément à une question c'est vrai
que moi depuis que j'ai pris mon poste
la fois où j'étais sollicité en direct
pour qu'on puisse traiter ça avait été
le fait ça avait été fait notamment par
le sous-préfet au mois de mai 2022 mais
moi dès le j'ai été sollicité
par le maire par le biais de ce courriel
qui relatait en fait des échanges entre
le collectif anticada et le maire et
donc un engagement pris que le la
préfecture au niveau départemental
reçoivent le collectif anti-cada j'ai
évidemment souscrit c'est le sens de
l'appel du secrétaire de que j'ai
demandé à mon secrétaire général le 4
avril de passer en direct et en mon nom
propre expressément Homère pour lui dire
qu'on allait honorer cet engagement et
qu'on allait organiser cette réunion
pour j'allais dire prendre en direct
cette sollicitation donc j'ai aussi été
attentif y compris dans cette dimension
sur le fond du dossier et sur
l'accompagnement du dossier en tout cas
voilà j'ai essayé de l'être
parfait merci peut-être monsieur sous
préfet je regarde l'horloge on se dit
que vers moins quart on arrête
[Musique]
peut-être
parce qu'elles allaient en séance
peut-être quelques éléments
complémentaires monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs sénateurs
je j'ai déjà j'avais déjà donné un
certain nombre d'indication dans mon
dans mon propos
sur sur le nombre de réunions publiques
il y a eu un choix dès l'origine par la
mairie de limiter les réunions publiques
à la
population directement concernée par ce
par le nouveau lieu d'implantation je
rappelle qu'il existe si ce n'est pas un
cada du moins quelque chose qui
ressemble fortement aujourd'hui sur un
quartier de Saint-Brévin et qu'il
s'agissait si je puis dire simplement
d'un transfert de cette population avec
un parti d'agrandissement mais en fait
c'était pas un changement de dimension
d'un transfert d'une d'une partie de la
commune sur une autre partie et donc le
les demandeurs d'asile ou les migrants
présents sur la commune depuis plusieurs
années ne posant pas de problème le
choix a été fait
par par la commune en réunion avec
l'opérateur de d'avoir des réunions très
localisées et c'est ce qui explique
aussi que dans un premier temps c'est
l'absence de contestation assez réunions
a fait que c'est l'opérateur qui a mené
des discussions qui étaient j'allais
dire d'explication semi technique mais
qui
ne nécessitait pas a priori
l'intervention d'un membre du camp
préfectoral je rappelle je voudrais
d'ailleurs signaler que je vous ai
indiqué que la première contact avec le
maire sur ce sujet de ma part c'était le
11 mars 2021 pour vous donner une idée
quatre jours après le 15 mars 2021 dans
une autre commune du de l'arrondissement
commune qui a été longtemps celle de
nouveau anciens collègues le sénateur
triard une une un projet de création
d'une ferme destinée à des sortants de
de sortants de prison avec créé une
émotion assez forte une manifestation et
le maire m'ayant demandé d'aller
expliquer avec les services de la
démonstration pénitentiaire le projet
j'ai tenu donc quatre jours après avoir
averti le maire de Saint-Brévin qu'on
allait transférer le CADA j'ai tenu une
réunion qui a été d'ailleurs comme on
peut s'y attendre dans ce type de
réunion assez houleuse et depuis il
m'est arrivé assez fréquemment de tenir
des réunions publiques avec les élus
quand
il me le souhaitait ou qu'il me
sollicitait pour les accompagner sur sur
des réunions publiques j'en ai tenu avec
le maire de Pornic quand on a quand on a
présenté la modification du PLU qui qui
pouvait susciter un certain nombre de
positions avec avec pas mal d'habitants
de la commune de Saint-Nazaire sur des
questions de sécurité qui sont qui sont
des sujets assez prégnants et encore
récemment et où on l'entend
effectivement c'était pas le cas pour le
permis de Pornic mais sur des réunions
de sécurité où on entend des propos
qui peuvent être assez choquants dans
l'expression que certains de nos
concitoyens or de leur de leurs
problèmes mais je le répète pendant
toute une période ce n'était pas le cas
ça me reste et lorsque
les choses ont commencé à la
contestation a commencé à surgir et que
j'en étais avisé j'ai invité les
opposants à une réunion d'explication et
je vous ai décrit la suite des contacts
j'ai eu sur ce sujet ensuite il faut
bien il faut bien voir que dans dans les
manifestations et dans la montée des des
problèmes sur Saint-Brévin il y a deux
aspects il y a un collectif composé de
personnes
assez locales j'allais dire presque de
voisins du futur site qui est qui sont
qui étaient opposés à l'installation du
CADA sur ce site là et puis il y a eu
une forme je sais pas si on peut parler
de récupération mais enfin ça on en est
pas très loin et madame la sénatrice à
tout à l'heure évoqué la question de
Calac ou effectivement
un certain nombre de
responsables de militants de régionaux
ou nationaux après ce qui s'est passé à
Callac ce sont joints
aux personnes qui étaient en petits
nombres opposés et les premières
manifestations sont des manifestations à
la fois assez pacifiques et avec un
petit nombre de personnes les
manifestations suivantes ont été
effectivement plus importantes mais là
on était plus dans la concertation on
était dans la manifestation dure et nous
avons pris les mesures comme je l'ai
indiqué assez longuement nous avons pris
les mesures pour que ces manifestations
se déroulent le mieux possible compte
tenu de la réglementation en la matière
que monsieur le Président vient de
rappeler
il y a eu une question sur sur les
informations du préfet évidemment le
préfet était impermanence informé de la
situation sur place Monsieur le Préfet
depuis son arrivée et son prédécesseur
évidemment avant à partir du moment
naturellement où les problèmes se sont
posés
et d'ailleurs c'est toujours sur c'est
souvent des courriers qui parvenaient à
la préfecture et qui ensuite qui ensuite
mettait mettait retranscrit
un certain nombre de tracts ont été
diffusés ces tracts
[Musique]
leur contenu
pouvait être extrêmement discutable
mais et de ce fait c'est la gendarmerie
a effectuer dès que les la situation a
commencé à se tendre des contrôles sur
les personnes qui distribuaient ces
tracts après ils ne nous appartient pas
d'empêcher des gens de distribuer des
tracts ça relève là aussi de la peau
d'une procédure judiciaire si on
considère que ces tracts sont à un titre
quelconque injurieux diffamatoire ou ou
posant problème dans la mesure où les
tracts sont diffusés pacifiquement on
n'a pas de possibilité de s'opposer à
leur distribution
les je rappelle en ce qui concerne
l'intervention des menaces que c'est
dans une période relativement récente
que
j'ai été informé que
la situation non seulement se traduit
par des manifestations ce qui comme je
le dis dans certains projets peut être
assez habituel que se traduisait par une
mise en cause directe des élus en fait
je n'en était avisé que par le courrier
que le maire a envoyé au préfet le 23
janvier et ça a donné lieu à une à cette
réunion dont j'ai assez longuement
évoqué du 10 février où je rappelle bien
deux points distinction entre la liberté
d'expression et la liberté de
manifestation qui sont des libertés
publiques fondamentales de notre pays et
Le
Loutre passage de ces de ces libertés
l'abus de ces banques de ces libertés
qui peut constituer des appels à
aux injures des menaces les menaces
étaient pas parlé vraiment de menace
c'était plutôt des propos
violents outrageants mais plutôt dirigé
contre les migrants je rappelle c'était
une liste de faits divers intervenus un
peu partout en Europe dans lequel des
migrants pouvaient être un titre ou un
autre être impliqué il n'y avait pas de
menaces
directes contre contre les élus si ce
n'est la demande que j'ai déjà mentionné
d'une forme de consultation locale sur
le sur le choix du site
je crois que un de vous mais Madame ou
Monsieur sénateur a parlé d'échecs du
CADA il y a pas d'échec du cadavre à ce
jour la construction du cadavre se
poursuit le le bâtiment est en cours est
en cours de construction le cadas sera
livré en novembre 2023 et pour il pourra
ouvrir à et pourra ouvrir au début
d'année 2024
je rappelle en outre que
le choix le choix du site d'implantation
si on peut dire a été proposé par
l’amérique qui a vendu le bâtiment au
bailleur social pour y installer le CADA
je me vois pas dans une situation à
expliquer à un maire que il a pas le
choix de son site d'implantation de tel
ou tel installation sur sa commune
justement la première discussion qui a
que nous avons eu c'était sur sur le
site entre le site je puis dire actuel
sur un bâtiment qui est un ancien centre
de vacances et la le souhait de la
commune de proposer plutôt et de céder
donc à notre site à notre site
d'implantation
alors est-ce que est-ce que nous avons
des études d'impact significatif
systématique sur l'intention d'un cada
non je n'ai on a une réflexion locale
sur la façon d'un cada il n'y a pas de
processus
normalisé de
d'ailleurs et je dirais que ça serait
que ça me paraît d'autant plus difficile
que chaque situation est très différente
vous avez signalé tout à l'heure
monsieur le sénateur est-ce que nous
allons ouvrir d'autres cadas il existe
d'autres cadas sur le département de
Loire-Atlantique des cadas diffus des
cadavres
concentrés si je veux dire collectif
pardon
dont vous n'avez jamais entendu parler
et moi non plus je dirais que on peut
difficilement savoir à l'avance quel
type de projet va susciter une
opposition ou pas même si on sait que
certains projets sont plus mal acceptés
que d'autres en l'espèce ce cadala dont
franchement aucun signe précurseur ne
nous permettait de penser qu'il serait
contesté je l'ai déjà indiqué à
plusieurs reprises compte tenu de la
présence d'un nombre très significatifs
de migrants depuis des années sur cette
commune et qui n'ont jamais posé de
difficultés particulières il n'y a pas
de de signalement de délinquance c'est
la sécurité ou de problèmes particuliers
et comme je l'ai dit indiqué au début de
la de la vie même du maire puisque
c'était une conversations que nous avons
eu peut-être avant d'arriver
sur
mais de manière très très anodine est-ce
que ça pose des problèmes non ils sont
là depuis des années et depuis deux
trois années quand je suis arrivé et ça
ils n'ont au début il y a eu un peu de
contestation et puis ça n'a pas posé de
difficultés
alors est-ce que
est-ce que on aurait pu faire davantage
moi je me rends compte a posteriori que
dans les contacts que j'ai eu avec le
maire je n'ai pas perçu
dans le notamment dans la conversation
téléphonique que j'ai eu avec lui qui a
été assez longue le jour où il a été
victime de l'incendie je n'ai pas perçu
et je crois l'avoir dit de
situations de détresse et j'ai
probablement pas il y avait peut-être
des signaux faibles qui mettaient
envoyés je ne les ai pas perçus je
trouvais le maire
très cohérent dans son dans son discours
nous sommes interrogés assez longuement
sur ce qui vous pouvez provenir c'est
cette agression je rappelle que le jour
même nous avions des manifestations
extrêmement violentes sur le pont de
Saint-Nazaire lié à la réforme des
retraites et c'était une des hypothèses
qui a été évoquée je lui ai demandé si
j'avais pris des positions qui
pourraient dans cette matière là il m'a
répondu que non et donc par la suite
il a il a considéré que l'agression dont
il avait été dans ta vie était victime
soit c'est bien et lui-même par
extension était lié à l'affaire du CADA
ce qui est fort possible mais pour le
moment aujourd'hui rien ne le démontre
expressément il n'y a pas il n'y a
jamais eu de revendications comme je
l'ai dit et il n'y a pas eu de à ma
connaissance en tout cas la procédure
vous dira peut-être à quelque chose mais
en tout cas de procédure permettant
d'incriminer telle ou tel type de
d'individus dans dans l'agression dans
l'agression en cause
je ne sais pas si j'ai répondu à toutes
vos questions
moi j'en ai une très très courte avant
qu'on lève la séance
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure la
lettre que vous envoyez le mail le 23
janvier
du surpassion de boîte mail
d'utilisation de boîte mail des
associations des parents d'élèves et
c'est justement parce que ce courrier
nous nous interpelle que on organise
avec le directeur général d'horreur
France ces réunions avec à la fois les
membres du collectif qui se sentent
visés puisqu'ils sont ils apportent leur
soutien au migrants qui se sentent visés
première réunion et la deuxième réunion
avec les élus de la commune
merci bien s'il y a pas d'autres
questions nous arrivons au terme de
notre audition oui Le Bourget juste une
question à laquelle je n'ai pas eu de
réponse et je me permets d'insister là
dessus parce que je vous avoue qu'il
s'envolait beaucoup surpris ainsi que de
nombreux collègues je vous ai posé la
question est-ce que l'un ou l'autre vous
êtes allé à Saint-Brevin pour témoigner
le soutien de l'État au maire de
Saint-Brévin ce qui nous avait surpris
et qui m'avait moi personnellement
heurté c'est d'apprendre que l'un ou
l'autre était allé à Pornic 48 heures
après l'incendie pour aller à Pornic il
faut obligatoirement passer par
Saint-Brevin et personne n'avait pris le
soin de s'arrêter à Saint-Brevin qui a
15 à 20 minutes je regardais sur ma paye
itinéraire ni à l'aller ni au retour
pour rendre visite au maire de
Saint-Brevin et ça je ne le comprends
pas
je rappelle qu'à ce moment là ça se
passe deux jours après
l'incendie des véhicules
j'ai eu le maire le jour de l'incendie
je n'ai pas perçu de demande
particulière de sa part à ce moment-là
peut-être à tort
semble-t-il à tort mais et je voulais
indiquer compte tenu du vous connaissez
les les habitudes en matière
d'inauguration il y a souvent les maires
des environs qui sont qui sont invités
le maire de la de la communauté de la
présidente de la Communauté de Communes
pouvaient être invité et je pensais
qu'il était j'étais un peu étonné qu'il
ne le soit pas présent mais
j'ai pas ensuite eu le réflexe de
l'appeler pour lui dire je viens je
viens chez vous c'est exact
bien
oui Monsieur le Préfet au sénateur
non comme je vous l'ai indiqué je suis
pas assez un Brévin après l'incendie
en revanche je vous l'ai dit c'est vrai
que si on fait abstraction du contexte
qui était très contraint en termes
d'ordre public je pense que mon réflexe
aurait été aurait été de présenter comme
j'essaie de le faire au maximum en
allant en allant auprès des élus
je suis retourné à Saint-Brevin par la
suite et j'ai rencontré mais j'ai
rencontré l'adjoint à la sécurité pas le
maire lui-même je suis retourné quelques
jours après à
non non après après l'incendie des
véhicules après l'incendie des véhicules
merci messieurs merci merci cher
collègue nous levons la séance bonne
soirée à tous